fake hair and real stories where I come  from a lot of women have fake hair I  often wear wigs or have extensions  played it into my natural hair and  sometimes the hairstyle can take up to  two days it's a lot of time that needs  to be filled so people at the salon talk  about their lives it's not just the  women who are here to have their hair  done you often have people coming in and  out just to have a chat it's because you  have here a level of trust that you  hardly find anywhere else and this trust  leads to better stories I became a  journalist because I want to be a  storyteller and I want to find those  real authentic stories about everyday  people who have something to share now  with all the time I've spent at the  salon  I know high quality hair when I see it  and a good story when I hear it my name  is Elizabeth Shaw and I work at GW  [Music]